hey everyone thank you so much for
tuning in to GameSpot after dark episode
25 this week we're joined by no clips
Danny O'Dwyer as he tells us about his
doom eternal experience and a bunch of
other stuff so check out the description
below
we have timestamps for everything and
without further ado hello welcome to
episode 25 of GameSpot after dark we are
back this week with a packed episode as
you can see if you're watching on video
we've got Danny O'Dwyer here hey hey
doing doing good how are you thanks
goodbye thanks for having me it's great
to be here it's been a hot minute since
I was here it's been a matter since I
was on a podcaster disc oh yeah it's
been awhile and the set has changed
quite a bit
great looking great podcast audience and
then tomorrow Hussein is with us hello
I'm back I'm ready to podcast and loose
James I was not here last week but
anyway we're gonna start with the Chris
from Dayton Ohio segment which we
haven't actually done in a while to
introduce Danny then we're gonna get
into what what we've been playing we're
gonna go right into topics we're just
gonna cry about all the games that got
delayed yeah real good news week and all
right and then we have some dancers that
we're gonna get into I hope they're
actually not I hope not
and then finally listener questions to
round out the show but yeah let's start
out with the Chris from Dayton Ohio
segment you know do you want to hear the
story behind this I know it I've
listened to the pocket okay alright well
then without further ado Daniel Dwyer
who are you thank you very much to work
yeah my name is Danny I used to work
here at GameSpot I worked actually my
I've worked before here I worked at
GameSpy UK and before case why UK we met
on games on games before I mean it's
more around a independent game site
called citizen game what name said what
am I
never remember that the Jerrod buttless
the movie yeah yeah that came out as
gamer in the end yeah so like there was
a minute where the movie gamer was
caught citizen game pre-production we're
like well that's our SEO or maybe it
helped us I was like hit that lawyers
are gonna come for us how much they like
you believe in this movie right yeah the
500 people who listen to our podcast
will really appreciate it that's the
holding on to that one and yeah it was a
yeah we we met on your Orochimaru sama
or so with me yeah forms and yeah we
were you on the forums I was just maybe
I was Daniel I think it was Daniel Dwyer
I was Daniel O'Dwyer on Steam forever ID
changer um yeah and we are a bunch of us
met who kind of were around most of us
tend to be in the UK there's couple of
other ones and when I moved to London
and to try and get into games while UK
it turned out he was like one tube
stopped up for me I was in Stratford in
Europe and Lynn's family in stone yeah
so he used to do podcasts in my spare
room and strucker's what tied beside the
Olympic Stadium yeah so that's the first
time we've done a podcast since I think
I don't think we ever did we have you on
games why UK when I was there or I don't
know cuz guy was no podcast yeah I
wasn't there there that time yeah Danny
was working somewhere else at that time
and then you joined UK after I left left
yeah you move I was here then here yeah
I like very briefly yes so as I joined
you left right yeah I kept missing each
other yeah so we can talk and they do as
well no we did dancers we did dancers
yes life advice there's 183 when we were
here too it's a life advice podcast a
day without a rikers on giantbomb he is
also now left job and see everything
everybody messed up it's all over the
place it's all broke a timeline yeah
but for the past three and a half years
I've been working well I guess now I'm
back in the Bay Area but I'm all over
the place on a thing called noclip it's
we make documentaries about video games
and that's pretty much all we do I've
got a new studio set up it looks great
in Emeryville right arounds not too far
from here basically the other side of
the Bay Bridge were like right there and
when you know you live there studio
that's how we pay for the rent is also
Bay Area prices
Shantanu Mike Mike oh my landlord it's
like Micah yeah yeah so we just yeah
we've myself and Jeremy Jane of course
who also used gamespot yeah he's he's
the shooter for John Baum or for no
cliff and he colors all our work and now
he's editing stuff because we're we have
a studio and we're actually sort of
diving in a bit more and doing a bit
more trying to get a bit more work out
there yeah cool back down yeah all the
most comprehensive Chris from Dayton
Ohio segment it's cuz I'm Irish now
known as shut up so I need one of you
that's all you here for just for that we
get on with the show well that's well to
be honest one of the things that happens
after you well I don't know if it's true
for everyone but certainly for me after
you leave the games price is that you
suddenly stop you you start getting out
of step with the frenetic pace of like
game launches yeah and some sometimes
you're just months behind and then other
times you're a little bit closer to it
so yeah in a way I feel like it's gonna
be kind of interesting looking at all
the news cuz I'm like I usually find
this a from listening to the podcast so
I well so what was what was the last I
guess big game that you played on
release day then oh like you still like
play these games don't really stay for a
little bit but then just come back to
them when I'm yeah I feel like I'm
usually playing I usually don't try and
start them there's two things that
happens one I have a daughter is a year
and a half years old so that sucks at
loads of time oxygen in the room right
away so you have to be then you're like
really selective about why you're doing
and then on top of that with all the
documentaries we do we tend to do them
after the games came out yeah so I'm
kind of in this both me my wife are we
to send him any more because you can't
with kids or you can leave her with
parents whatever but we don't tend to so
all all the movies we watch are like
nine months later on Amazon right when
they finally go up for rental and it's
the same with games where I tend to you
know I spent a lot of outer walls at the
end of the year because we did a dog
that was maybe actually the last game I
played the week it came out right before
e3 and I remember I remember had a golf
in time because III was coming off that
you know when you're applying for e3 and
then yeah you kind of know nothing else
is going on and I had a couple of days I
was like oh I'll play it but that was
probably the last one what ask big came
out last year I'm trying to think like I
just recently secured I tried like I pay
maybe four days of it realized I just
wasn't in that space where I could you
know really commit to autonomy yeah
relearn it I guess
totally and I backed off and then disco
was probably which was GameSpot's latest
ten out of ten right you know yeah I
thought was one of the reasons I went
and it was Callie's in her review was it
no no it was no it was a while yeah
another game I played over the Christmas
break because you know everyone been
talking about it yeah you like it I
really read it I like the more than I
thought because I'm not really a big I
guess see RPG with me it's really smart
out of it and I went out and I think
Gregg and Jenn ruin the the kitchen they
were like oh how's the game I was like I
think this is the best game it was an
hour in like we had like I was speaking
to the PR behind and they don't like
we've got this you want to exclusive
trailer for this little C RPG game yeah
it's called disco dzm I was like disco
sounds good yeah I saw like some
screenshots for it now I'm like hair and
then I was like yeah we'll run it and
like that from then on like it kept an
eye on it and then we got it a little
bit we got a preview of it right so we
got preview built and played I was like
this is yeah this is something I think
it was I think it was for community
Fridays which was when Ben and John Luke
play they just pick a game to play with
community Friday and they got an email
from the developers saying like hey you
guys should play Disko Elysium for
coming
Fridays and I remember I think John Luke
was like yeah it seems cool but this is
like not the kind of game it's really
gonna work for this setting which is
wild because that was I don't know it
was probably a year before the game came
out or something like that
and then it came out and like sweat like
it was just like hummed along the entire
time everyone's like yeah maybe this
will be good but like and then orange
man everyone went oh my lord they just
blew up from that point on it's like an
impossible game for like a press
conference or show forward yeah it just
doesn't come across like you really need
to be in the weeds with her for an error
so at the video you guys did here was
absolutely fantastic behind it audio
logs yeah yeah we shot with Robert for I
don't know ha and it's it's frustrating
when you have to cut it down to 17
minutes but especially like in the video
and he's like this goes 1 million words
and I think a perfect game is 2 million
or something like people get called a
genius all the time right but like
watching him like the way he describes
things like where the text box is and
how it tumbles up and like the the thing
that he's like very casually almost like
humble way goes like I think this is
pretty clever yeah we put this in the
corner because it's where the system
tray is I was like this guy's kind of a
genius he's an actual understated genius
in the way that like a lot of people
claim to be like he's not out there
claiming to be a genius but I would
think like hmm in terms of what he's
written some of the design things that
he discusses in audio logs like he's
like no one likes dragging rhombuses
sort of and like things like his insight
into people as well like people like to
look at text but don't absorb the
texture generation right or the idea
that we don't read yeah all we're doing
is reading also we're reading the basic
stuff and like the the way that the text
is all the dialogue is designed to be
aggressive towards you to kind of like
shock your voice why you always been
called like a pig in etc etc like that's
that's galaxy brings like a second
language as well yeah
is legit galaxy brain design and like I
would like home be comfortably call him
a genius
oh yeah he's incredible my favorite
thing he said was that they had no idea
how to do the thought cabinet but he
said like any game designer from the
Molyneux School of game design I was
talking about the promise of it and he'd
spent all this time it shows just Toki
[ __ ] its feature that they had no idea
how to implement and they were like
thankfully he landed the kickflip unlike
which Molyneux sort of sometimes didn't
sometimes then yeah we got to do a nice
little motion graphic of an echo and for
that yeah uh Danny you got to check out
doom
I did do eternal and yet they do fan too
so this is perfect to have you here to
talk about this well I really liked doom
I like all the dooms I pretty much like
any game it made even the weird ones
like I really liked rage - last year I
vided - yeah
they just know how to do shooting really
well and I like you know people play
games for different different reasons
and like I think that for me was a
really good Ubisoft game where it was
just like oh oh Ubisoft for me there's
just totally big checklist but in a lot
of those games I don't enjoy the
third-person action very much but in
rage already did so I kind of liked all
of them obviously
toom 2016 took everyone by storm I still
remember being here in the office and
talking to Peter about it before because
the scuttlebutt before that game came
out was they had a they had a weird
embargo so everyone was like oh they had
that thing where they were like we're
not gonna talk to any press wasn't it or
something like it was around the time
the Pete Hines and them were kind of
yeah yeah you'll get it the day off
and people like dishonored Dishonored 2
is the same year yeah decide today it
was a because every bit as they're
related it's all related game with like
no press are gonna see yes
you'll get it to they are and that
result in people going like Oh for Doom
is that a bad idea
yeah what's that the same thing is press
sneak I'm not swearing on this but
because of that whole thing like there
was no marketing yeah there was no word
of mouth going around about yeah yeah
there was that word was a lot of like
like yeah his sort of what no quality
around was III that yeah that was the
big dishonoured stuff that they did it
was like a half hour I've just
dishonored oh really
thanks yeah cuz doom 2016 came out on
our March I was it macho so they
would've missed up but I don't remember
anything from 20 it might have been just
over here well no 15 43 was fall out
those big fall out and I think there's a
little bit of doom and I think that was
part of the reason why it's like alright
Bethesda's big game fallout 4 has
already come out and like people saw
doom and it looked it looked fun but it
was until you actually got to play it
everyone hated like the glory kills
everyone was suspect about none of the
names they remembered like Marty
Stratton had been there since I I think
almost as long as Tim well it's yeah
that sage Tim wasn't working on it he
was working on whatever for something
else at the time quick champions they
they go us and so there was like all
these other you know super I guess a lot
of doubts behind it or whatever and then
obviously comes out everyone's loves it
I remember talking to Peter but he was
like I think it's really like I think
it's a like and then Brad was really
into it and stuff and yeah but for this
one I was it's that sophomore slump
problem that you know it's difficult
second album like hair today a pitch
what direction do they go in and and
from talking to them
I mean Hugo talks a good talk the guys
to be comedian so he knows how to like
he's done stand-up he knows that it's
not surprising yeah and he's super nice
guy and I like him to bits but I you
know like anyone he's gonna like talk
confidently made his game but when I sat
down a plated the game just feels like
so much more confidence like it's like
before I think they also had to be
really like delicate with this cherished
franchise if it's like a seemingly new
generation of dads coming in and taking
something like doom and then adding one
up thing or you know one up heads and
like jumping and climbing mechanics like
they played it a little bit close but
they were a little fast in the
with some of the especially the
self-aware tone and all that sort of
stuff what I like in this one is not
just the tone in a way that sounds sort
of like hums along it the same way it
was in the last game but just they just
leaned into this as a goddamn video game
and it's it's just like by steering into
it they've made it like such more
interesting moment to moment game where
you kind of have to like like you're
saying within disco where they
constantly calling your Pig to like
arrest you and keep you there yeah this
game I give you sleep for a second if
you just go into like rocket League
autopilot mode like you olds a goal will
go in you know like you need to be on
top of it you'll die and I really liked
it yeah yeah Mike Ohio so for us and is
written up a bunch of he's written up a
preview and this videos as well and I
remember I was cueing the preview and
like if you remove I was reading the
preview and I thought to myself if you
remove anything that identifies this
game as doom
like just the word doom from him and
just read the description it sounds like
a platinum game
it's Devil May Cry which is that was
like yeah this sounds like a legit like
Japanese planning game like character
action game and that made me way more
excited yeah very excited for it but now
I'm like the synergy between abilities
and the movement and kind of like
keeping you on your toes and always
focused and engaged sounds incredible
like I'm so excited to play that game
now and yeah way more demons you start
you like you're on like a fortress of
doom which is this weird castle like
okay that's floating off in space and
you transport the different parts of the
earth like I want to know where we do is
there like a London level I don't know
like it doesn't look like they're you
know descriptions of modern cities or
whatever and I did it look on look
there's a map where it has like world
world portals or wherever all the bad
shit's gone on and yeah England was
screwed guys sorry
I loved doom 1 but the one thing I
remember at doom 1 is not our doom 2016
I guess was not being able to just sit
there and play all day because like you
were saying it just demanded my
attention the entire time right so I'm
excited for eternal but I'm also nervous
about how much I can play of that game
because I found that game like I don't
to say exhausting because that sounds
bad but I could do a level and then I
had to step away and catch my breath and
like I don't know drink beer and then
come back in and tell another level I
couldn't play doom 2016 for a different
reason that is it makes me incredibly
emotions really yeah and I played it so
I picked it up I didn't pick it up when
it came out but I picked it up I'm ahead
of e3 this year because I was like well
it probably gonna have the doom
interview yeah I should play 2016 and I
picked it up cheap on PSN warf really
right away you can't change like field
of view and anything and it's just have
you had that with our games I can't do
VR ok I can do I can do vive because I
can't do PlayStation VR right Tetris
effect in PlayStation VR you can't rekt
me that's emitted at you're basically
like that still yeah that's very I don't
know if I'm just hypersensitive to that
kind of thing like um I I got I get
motion sickness and I have the same
thing and when I played it on ps4 I
think it was it made me so sick he's
saying I wanted to try it on peaceful
winter PC because you can mess with the
fov on the write out different things
like that like motion blur and that kind
of stuff and I found the sweet spot and
it was incredible and it's weird cuz it
used to be a much more of a problem when
you know oculus was first starting and
everyone was throwing software into
their thing and you would go to all
these press events and I remember one
press event it was a first-person
adventure game and they had this it had
a button to crouch Oh immediately your
character goes down and you stood there
I just took the thing off
SiC I left and I was fine but then the
the actual developer had to demo the
rest of it and he said well actually I
can't play VR either so it makes me
incredibly sick oh my god dang I had
there was one demo I did and I think it
was it was a horror game the one in it's
like set in a hospital remember which I
know you're talking about I played that
game but I used the teleporting yeah
system and like it started to make me
feel sick so I got around it by every
time I moved I closed my eyes slightly
like that and I open it like and I'd it
would just be a normal thing and then
the next thing I'd like those Doctor Who
statues and it was like a circuit of
games so you do like a bunch of alright
the next one I go on the next one iconic
tough mudders was exactly it was like it
was a mountain bike oh great yeah did
you ever see the mountain with more flew
were flies yes and you start pedaling
and if you go to view your headset
you're on a horse yeah and then like the
developer did not tell me what happens
like a Pegasus so like you're riding a
horse and like by pedaling the horse is
going quicker and then once you hit a
certain speed you just start flying
yeah and like it happened you can't just
[Music]
motion sickness story do you remember
this was the games come that I went to
with you I'm Peter Brown and I went to
play Mirror's Edge to someone I think we
got we have games for always parks up in
this we don't have a room we just Park
up in that little concourse next our
office just like yeah that's like the
side of the static and I went straight
from that demo
I wasn't feeling good right and then I
was handed we've got like lunch
sandwiches and I had this I remember an
exile it's a oh and I took one bite and
then I threw up in the bin on the
concourse next to the stairs
and then immediately filmed those
impressions oh really yeah but funnily
enough did not play Mirror's Edge
catalyst well I hope for you to that
half-life alex has allowing settings and
you're able to get through that to be
like think about that stuff they feel
like they have to write they've got like
they can't let screw it up especially
with index like being their big thing
maybe to make it as like available to as
many people as possible
do you trust them to get it out in March
cuz we're like the end of January right
polish now they don't anticipate a delay
all right they didn't yeah yeah I don't
think they can delay it I feel like they
would look pretty like you've waited
this long you might as well just wait
until it was ready before you're gonna
know if you're gonna delay it they did
an AMA this morning like it's it's
pretty much time really polishing it
yeah
doom is out the week at GDC so I just
don't want any other game that week
because we're gonna be wins Animal
Crossing game so much that it bleeds
into life yeah so then you just be like
why isn't cake a slight a murdering
everyone or like always Tom Knox head I
like have that thing cuz I've played a
lot of Rainbow six siege whenever I see
one of those cameras that are round like
oh yeah shoot that out peeking around
cards doing the Stanley for me that
reminds you spinner so that's like yeah
yeah I've been asking tomorrow and I
everyone 3d soft predictions were like
were you a spoiler study this year oh my
god I can't even fool myself anymore
any final thoughts on doom eternal at
least from what you saw the version they
brought seems to be complete they I bet
there was technical problems editor
crashed a bunch of times but like the
actual game seems like it's kind of
there has a soundtrack
yeah like the one thing that came across
I was trying to listen for as a member
Gordon put a call out two years ago for
metal singers all around the world so we
can build a metal like choir and I think
that's what I heard there was there's
way more vocalization in the soundcheck
this time around but it sounded like
yeah like bitching like I was believing
not going like I'm like editing a
feature back in the studio at the moment
and being like God I wish that so what's
the music first yeah was it this is a
weird question but like it was the metal
vocal stuff just always on it was it one
of those games things mechanics parts
like the better you're doing the more
the vocal comes in I think because the
old the do 2016 they did have like the
songs ended after doze because the
encounters in the game were so like
structured like like arena combat right
and then you're in the - a little bit in
the militant arena combat and so it was
that way but the thing that the
vocalizations seemed to be in when you
were sort of engaging with the more
hellish natures of the because there's a
lot of like occultist stuff going on in
it so whenever you were and it's really
funny because they just breeze through
the story like you're you're talking to
people who like seem to know who you are
and the personalization or
characterization of the doom Slayer is
like way like more there but they're but
they're still not really talking about
you still have to read like you they
never really stop to like tell you okay
this is what's happened this is how long
is gone since doom 2016 because like
arts [ __ ] at this stage so you're kind
of like you know what's going on or who
are these people and but same as the
last game you have to use the Codex and
pick up all the extra details to figure
out which is kind of cool it's like a
weird eye telling the story but it gets
re did you get the bit where you get
collectible and fist-bump it yeah I got
a I got ya cuz in the route because in
the in the original game it was they're
like but they were all like versions of
the doom Slayer now it's the demons it's
pretty cool so I got a bobblehead of
like a like a cyber mastermind or a rock
Neutron we're not one of the others and
I got another one of them yeah and he he
took it I don't think either the
fist-pump but he picked it up and they
look so cute like they look like
did you stored up a Thesz de Vaca did
you go to the doom Slayers like living
quarters or whatever oh my god says I
heard about this I don't know it's in it
oh really
so yeah this is the ship that you're on
the fortress of doom is it snow and is
like it's basically yeah he's like hob
or whatever and has all that my favorite
thing that's in there and they make you
go through it after the second level for
like a little tutorial stuff to really
have you oh stop it start and way more
explicitly in the first game actually
and with a straight-up transports you to
like a hollow deck area and you do
something that you go back okay um but
uh he has they ever they have an area at
the bottom what's it called John look
probably Sheridan I think it's called
the demon prison or something yeah is
that what it is yeah and it's basically
just like he has a bunch of demons stuck
in a prison so we can just like test out
school alright then you take the
elevator back up it's so serious I think
I think it was called the ripped or iam
it's great so yeah they're not taking up
substances so excited for this game
anything else you've been playing
watching do it all really couple of
games of stuff that we're doing videos
on that I don't think I can Wednesday
this is going up this week Friday but
yeah just I don't know follow me on
Steam or PSN and if you if you want to
see what video documentaries are coming
out because I never block anything and
but yeah we're working on a bunch of
stuff we're gonna be we're gonna be in
Texas and France for one
[Applause]
questions and we're going to LA next
week for a short one um which isn't too
dissimilar from the last one we did kind
of okay terms of letters let's say oh
that one that you teased there yeah I
should that should be fun yeah
cool more I've been playing Dragon Ball
Z cracker oh crap Rock is it crap I'm
hearing mixed things you don't seem to
like you I was actually called oh okay
oh there you go no no no I feel like
people are actually really liking it so
I apologize you've spoken to me about it
yeah you know that's true but even
before you I was hearing I'm trying to
be that person that not too young
people's Young's I'm not gonna google it
for sure like I don't want to rain on
anyone's parade like as I see a lot of
people really enjoying it and they're
like it's got like a 75 on that strew to
find but like still a lot of the reviews
that went up they initially were like
from websites I've never even heard of
so like a lot of people are enjoying it
and I respect that people enjoying it
like I want respect cards cards on a
table unlike huge Dragon Ball fan I
think anyone can attest to that that
knows me like I love Dragon Ball grew up
watching it and like I'm very very
passionate close to my heart
vegeta san but like I played it and it
just did nothing for me
it's like the most it feels like I'm
Pierre described it best that's not
throw up here on the bus but like
absolutely throw at PC Brown and that's
why all right yeah
a soulless thing like it's it's easy to
look at and be like oh this cool because
why it is is
it's an RPG in the Dragon Ball universe
where you play through the you know the
most of the Dragon Ball Z anime you go
from the start say an arc to the end of
the Buu saga which is a whole chunk of
storylines and you relive the cold
battles and you do like RPG style doing
little missions but like I can just it's
icy through it like it's like you've
taken the Tenkaichi game you've taken
the Budokai game's the xenoverse games
the same like extremely basic like
no depth to it very little depth to it
fighting system and you've like strong
to strung it together using very
rudimentary surface level RPG systems
and like I almost don't want to say this
but like people are settling for it if
you're like I I feel like if I if I was
to like just delude myself and say I'm
really enjoying it I would be selling
for it and I think in a world like post
Dragonball flight is Z right we we
should expect that like if feels it
feels like a soul let's cash in like I
was watching it because it recreates the
anime hey so you know what's gonna I
know what's gonna happen in it I like
and I would watch iconic moments
happening and think to myself I should
just watch the anime because like I'm
not enjoying the fighting and like
there's parts of it that are like the
they skimped out on certain things
because video games are still expensive
to make and you know that just suck out
the charisma and this like the cinematic
quality of some moments as things like
there's an early moment where like one
of the key characters Gohan is a child
and he's just he's presented through the
star as like just sniffling crying like
spoiled brat but actually he's secretly
like one of the most powerful beings on
the planet
right but like he he only reveals that
in the in the show when his dad's almost
like being killed by someone and like he
there's a moment where he erupts out of
this like containment unit he's in a
spaceship it's like a seminal moment
yuria every frame I remember every
single frame of like I can draw the pose
I can tell you where each bit of rubble
is I can tell you the way his tail like
and the way like dramatic moment when he
erupts out there and everyone on the
battle flight field just looks at him
and it's like this kid about to unleash
in the in the game I was just like they
didn't set up all because to like land
that moment they show inside the
containment pod which is Raddatz is like
ship and like he's getting frustrated
and he's crying and you can see he can
hear like stuff happening around it
around him and then it builds to this
moment in the game it's just like a
couple of frames like the character
looks at the thing kid erupts and it
just moves on and like there's a sack
at the end of that battle where Goku
sacrifices himself to kind of kill the
bad guy and like even that isn't
animated properly and there's like other
moments where like Gohan being taught to
fly for the first time by a character
who is formerly like the biggest bad in
the Dragon Ball universe and like it's
like oh he's taking this kid under his
wing cuz Goku's now dead ends gonna
teach him how to be a fighter and like
it's alright we're gonna teach Gohan how
to fly it a text box appears it's like
hello tall Gohan how to fly it's like
what come on you're better than this
and like everywhere around the world is
like it's littered with these annoying
emblems that are like very gamey like
immediately pull you out the experience
and the side quests are like fishing
help you know be up on this character
that you're infinitely more powerful or
powerful then I played like four or five
hours and like you fly around a lot but
just just doesn't feel good it's like it
feels like controlling I hate to bring
it up like the gummi ship in Kingdom how
do you like Dragon Ball characters they
fly around like nimble moving around but
like in this like you leap up into the N
and it's like the elevation thing where
you're doing this constantly and like
it's like if you and they you you're
flying like that and then what they'll
do is they'll create massive circles of
the power-ups if you fly through the
middle it doesn't put all the power of
sin right so you kind of like know
you've to like you have to like this is
not cool at all it's not like I'm not
getting anything out of it and then you
get into the fights and the fights are
fine but like they don't there's no
depth to it like there's you over time
you like earn new moves and etc etc but
like the fundamentals of it are not
engaging like a good combat system is
good from the very start and then you
layer intricacies on top of it not to
like a backseat game design but like
that's how the best combat systems work
right from the very first moment you
play Bayonetta mmm vanilla bayonet is
amazing feels right feels good and then
you get more abilities and it gets
better and better
this game is like this is the it doesn't
feel any different from the ps2 ps3 this
all sounds like it reminds me of like
every licensed game ever yeah and it's
like like a very short dev time yeah
limited resources
get it out exactly and we were talking
about this earlier like the problem is
we're still a stage where anime games
are by default people will be saying or
settling for it there's no like HUD the
bar hasn't been raised for anime games
what was dragonfly disease why is easy
one game yeah it's one game like we're
stage now where open-world games good
open-world games are so like frequent
that people won't accept a bad one now
when a bad open-world game comes out we
can throw a dart at a list of open world
games and land on like ten different I
mean right one like play one of them you
can't have a bad game bad open-world
game in a world where Red Dead exists
Metal Gear exists you know all these
other many many open-world games
assassin's creed whatever it may be even
games that are like not technically open
world but I like pseudo open world do
they're open worlds well like that's the
bar the bar has been raised
Dragon Ball anime games like fight
Izzy's just like one run so people
fundamentally are still not at a stage
where they expect better expectations
and there's like wrestling games -
exactly like this guy's stuck with this
super pro yet it's like yeah like broken
relationship for years like you're even
don't know what else you're gonna do you
can't play anything else so if you're a
Dragon Ball phone you ever play the
Kakarot or you play nothing like you can
play fight a Z and fight as he is an
infinitely more better game and it takes
like the problem I have of anime games
is one there always boil down to arena
fires - they always completely miss the
point like the essence of what makes a
good fire anime game is always missing
fighters II understands the essence of
like rivalries incredible comeback
moments and it takes these core moments
and like like a special move like the
father-son coming home a hill which is a
moment in Dragonball where go hon he's
in the teens now he does this fireball
but like he's doing it to take kill one
of the biggest bad guys in the show like
and Goku's dead at the time but when
he's doing it he's
evoking his father so like deeply that
they show him during the fireball and
behind him you can see like the image of
his dad also doing the fire but like
they're connecting in that moment and
like something like that when it's put
into fire Z it's like the culmination of
a battle between two people like sonic
Fox and go ichi right when that happens
like that moment is infinitely more
powerful it feels like going to happen
in the movie because the tension around
it the fighting between the two people
is the drama and then it becomes this
you know this amazing moment and that's
what it understood like it took the
essence of what made all these things
cool like collecting the dragonballs
they put it into that system and this
game is like a very soulless recreation
like we've all Dragon Ball fans have
seen Dragon Ball now there's only so
many times you can retell this story
here we've all heard it and genuinely
this feels like a moment where the
developers Bandai Namco have gone we
can't make any more of this format of
Dragon Ball game
we need a new format of Dragon Ball game
for the next five years right so they've
gone RPG and the next five years are
gonna be iterating on this RPG hmm once
they've backed that into a corner and
nuclear drive you'll be another format
dansgame milk that and then do that and
it just feels like I hate being so
cynical about it but like I reached a
stage where bad anime games infuriate me
because I love anime and I see the
storytelling potential in a lot of them
just being squandered by arena fighters
like we've taken my hair academia came
out and my hair academia like you've
seen it it has funny in it let's no okay
yeah it's not about that it's about you
know like you watch my ear academia and
it's just about so much more than just
dude's punching each other but these
games like they're my hair academia came
out just reductive reduced it to
characters fighting and it's just like
you've missed the point again you're
just cashing in on this this this
license and you're like you're abusing
the goodwill of people that you know
other other you know the anime and the
manga creator has built up you're just
cashing in on it and it just makes me
sad and I just hate that exists and I'm
glad that people like hacker oh it's not
for me
if you can find the fun in it more power
to you I just expect better from it
yeah I mean I think of someone who loved
animate very much for anime doesn't play
jnanam a games
I remember seeing Dragonball fighters in
thinking like I want to play this game
because this game looks slick that's a
lot of fun like it seems like a lot of
fun
it seems pretty tight like polished so I
played it and I played I don't I didn't
I didn't finish the story it seemed
pretty long but I played a good amount
of it and I had a lot of fun and when I
heard of that the most on anime fan
thing the story was too long for you
really yeah
but then when I heard about Kakarot I
was like I might be interesting try and
I think I saw like 30 seconds of
gameplay I was like not doing this it's
such a shame it's such a shame like
anime fans demand para hmm like please
stop buying this trash I do wonder if
the market is big enough for it like I
don't know like it seems like anime is
more popular than Ana never was yes it
seemed it was really popular ten years
ago but I should say wonder I didn't
review this game like I'm not sure the
the the eventual score that goes up on
our website it won't be reflective of
games well as a whole I imagine it could
be the our review is aligned with me or
could be like they like it morning and
then I do like this is my specific
opinion your stance fires my stance on
it yeah I don't want it to be a solid
ball game like yeah I don't want the
situation to be like well you gave it at
nine here so what's going on this is my
opinion like that's that's who I am I'm
just a higher class of anime fan I think
speaking of anime looks like you also
have an anime down here that you've been
watching then you want to talk about uh
yeah I've been watching Psychopaths
three do you guys know about Psychopaths
I mentioned on my words I think you'd
like here as well so here's my pitch for
Psychopaths like opacities is I don't
want to compare to mine re Popeye
it's got similar things it effectively
takes place in the future where an AI
has been developed that can measure and
factor in your mental state and your
kind of lifestyle to calculate the
likelihood of you committing a crime oh
it's like my comm app
it's like more but at the same time what
happens is so like effectively your
latent there are people who could late
in criminal yeah
and people who have done like there's
hues like you're you're kind of like you
have a crime coefficient Hugh right and
like certain people have done things
that has clouded that hue that might not
necessarily illegal but you could work
in law enforcement okay and have seen so
many things that you're now technically
unstable so right even though you're a
good person right your crime coefficient
is at the point where you're dangerous
so you effectively become an enforcer so
you get treated as like your now
disposable right so you are paired up
with like a cop who's got a clear hue
but you do go okay it's god bad yeah so
effectively that's it like you get
treated as like a dog of the military or
the police force and like Psychopaths is
about the first season is about someone
who figures out how to subvert the
entire system and like
so basically abuse the system to turn
people who are perfectly fine into like
you know you know effectively people who
are deemed they're red red like and like
you you law enforcement will effectively
kill those people right so does everyone
like in this world know that that's a
thing that exists or is it like kind of
clandestine that's that's just the way
it is stable system but like the first
season explores the limits of it and
effectively it's all about how someone
comes along and he's a bit of a like a a
Moriarty type and his whole goal is I'm
gonna show you how this is all wrong
right and how it all like for his own
gain but it's all about that and then
it's an incredible credible like story
and also wealth I adore it and how many
episodes in a season say it's about 20
episodes okay well I wouldn't does the
Alina fighter come out for that there's
one game there's a game called
psychopathy mandatory happiness which is
perhaps a little closer to what you'd
want like they understand that
narrator's important part of this is all
then Psychopaths is quite a few years
old the the game itself is a few years
old as where I was on PSN plus for free
for a while but that's a visual novel
basically the story is not as strong but
it's it's at least understanding what's
important about Psychopaths it tries to
like yeah the first season was amazing
the second season was like it was lower
key it gets into quite like moral and
like philosophical deconstructions with
the first season was a little more like
action focus the third season is it's
wild I'm like I watched two episodes and
it's very it feels very very complicated
it's reached a point where now and
there's there's one character who's
effectively unfitted out how to connect
with another person like emotionally but
I'm still trying to figure that out
myself but like he's able to do it so
deeply that it becomes like almost a
mental thing as well right and they can
almost feel and experience remnants of
what they experienced so like in a scene
it could be like or someone was here and
they're able to like almost tune
themselves to this person and figure out
what they were getting like hints at
what they were doing
the last moment and it's all about like
understanding the mission like a drone
goes down and someone is killed and this
person seems to be just a
run-of-the-mill accountant so it's
almost like they're figuring out why
this happened
murder mystery kind of yeah and behind
the scenes there's a clandestine group
almost course almost playing oh is it
like using using the various like AI
systems that are like governing who's
good and who's bad to play this almost
like gambling game of chess so unlikely
a character from previous seasons is
kind of like constantly appearing but
it's unclear what her her ending point
in another season left her in a very
gray area because obviously she started
off as like a a cool I kind of like I'm
new cop everything's good but through
what she experienced ended up in a
situation where she's bad not bad but
like is it a little more of a danger to
herself and other people so she seems
that she's pulling some strings to try
and unravel what she's seen in the
entire time but it's incredible like
universe world-building just really
fascinating like really well-written
it's like if I almost feels like I hate
to bring it back to disco Elysium for
like you know how dense this go Elysium
yeah well you're like I can pick out so
many parts of this and it's really
satisfying that's what it's like where
you're like oh I want to understand what
crime coefficients are how does the
virtual world impact how's VR impact you
as a person like if you experienced
something in you know like what happens
to someone who's like a victim of a
crime like there's a scene in that in
the things in the first season where
someone sexually assaulted but because
of the trauma that they experienced the
hue is now clouded which means like they
are a candidate for enforcement right
they're technically a criminal like
what's the limits of the system they how
do you work around that what are you
obligated to now arrest that person
they've done nothing wrong like and how
is it what happens when someone appears
that crime is normal to them they're
like a serial killer for example a
circular doesn't think right yeah it's
orderly like can they do their people
exist where they can commit a crime but
because it has so little impact on them
disassociated yeah they're just they
just aren't changing their hue or like
their crime Cuoco fish fact of li
they're going invisible
what happens there it's like really
fascinating and like sounds much deeper
and way more thorough than Minority
Report it's really I highly recommend it
the third season it's the problem with
it is this never been super popular and
I think it's partly because it is quite
dense and it is quiet it's not in look
it's wauchula I watch it the first
seasons on Amazon Prime video the first
season I think is available in like
crunchyroll and Netflix it's one of
those things where it looks very cool
and almost like I'm gonna watch an anime
it's gonna be like cool stuff having any
rain you're like wow this is heavy man
so that's why I feel like it hasn't
always taken off and the writer behind
it is like a well-known like manga
artist Monica who's like known for
delving into like the darker sides of
storytelling in society and that kind of
stuff it's it's fantastic I recommend it
to everyone
psychopathy I got more on that on your
anime podcast tomb anime yeah we came up
with a video series for anime that we
pitched this even watching some shows -
yeah I haven't really been playing much
I dipped into the overwatch lunar event
mm-hmm good news means it's a it's what
capture the flag mode that we would
compare play pick'm bands allegedly
coming soon need some more heroes but
picking bands allegedly coming soon I
actually spent most of my long weekend
just watching a bunch of stuff on
Netflix so my roommates so jen is a
fellow crime Marina marina aficionado
and that new Aaron Hernandez
documentaries on Netflix and so it's
really good and I suggested it because I
was like let's go football in its that's
a Greg Greg Greg played peace walk at
the entire time he has like his little
second separate screen and he was just
playing peace walker so Jen and I got
through what the three of us go through
the whole thing in one sitting it's like
three episodes 3 hour-long episode ok
alright
but I didn't know anything about it it's
very well made it's a some bits of it
are massively overproduced already the
title sequence has no business being
that like elaborate elaborate is this a
netflix funded thing it's like my
biggest problem with like these netflix
funded documentaries it's just like you
don't need to spend this much money on a
title sequence kit anyway it's very very
good so we did that I blasted through
all of sex education season 2 in under
24 hours I don't think I've watched that
it's really good it's this weird mashup
of aesthetics where they're in the
modern day because they have mobile
phones and stuff but they're all dressed
in this weird mix of clothing from like
the 70s to the 90s okay and they're in a
place that's they're all British but
they're in what's based on an American
high school oh I have I know it okay
fantastic phenomenal phenomenal this sex
therapist whose son is also going to
this high school and she eventually gets
an even way more involved in the school
itself in the second season it's
produced show I think so and actually in
C there's a lot of stuff in England oh
yeah I think they do film it in the UK
but some of it doesn't look like the UK
so if it looks like Switzerland doesn't
okay really weird macho they use all the
old vintage cars to but then they have
these Rovers from the 90s really
interesting actually the inside of
everyone's house looks like this Gordy
sixties wallpaper with all these
mishmash of patterns it's really cool I
kinda like it when shows and movies
don't really announce what year it is
like there's a bunch of different like I
think it follows the phone or that use a
phone that's it's so good
blasted through it and like a day but
the other thing I've been watching The
Outsider I've watched the two
good so it's this it's a Stephen King
book I haven't right when I was a
teenager I would read nothing but
Stephen King and then cell came out and
I read cell and I went I'm done right so
I haven't read any Stephen King since
then I think the outside it was a couple
years ago if I remember I don't know I'm
not sure I know my roommate she said she
tried to read it and she was like I
couldn't do it was pretty boring and but
I was like you should try the show
because I think the show so far is tense
so if you cancelled your HBO
subscription after the watchman ideas
after finished Watchmen
cuz it was really good I back get it
back okay like oh like wait until the
whole things on Japan Jim I was like
this is boring so it is Ben Mendelsohn
and Jason Bateman and alt okay
Jason Bateman he directs almost all the
episodes yeah yeah which I didn't
realize until I kind of hit the end
credits yesterday but so my favorite
Jason Bateman I think I said this last
week is creepy Jason Bateman okay he's
fantastic obviously is Michael and
Arrested Development but when he's in
the gift or ozark and he has been an
edge to him
it's really weird he does it really so
well so in this obviously no spoilers
I'll just talk about the general premise
but it's it's in Georgia Ben Mendelsohn
is a police detective and he gets called
out because they found a dead child
exists 11 your boy that's pretty
gruesome - okay so I tried to start
watching it last week and I was a little
bit drunk when I came in and I'd ordered
some chicken that's just side betting it
and then they just show you this really
dismembered body of a small child
chicken go back to shits Creek we say
like it we're talking like a young
teenager 11 okay right yeah because the
child thing is a problem there might be
a boy and it's a boy I should be okay
and so then you have been medicine
troubled police detective in a small
town and very very quickly they sort of
narrow in on a suspect and it's Jason
Bateman and they can and he's you know
they're the football coach everyone
loves him
baseball and he's this family man and he
gets arrested every of the community all
just you think it's just a regular
police detective procedural and that you
can see where it's going halfway through
the first episode oh my god they also
play with music really well alright
there's a lot of just ticking and it
just builds this tension so so well and
last night so I watched two Liat the
first two episodes last night and I
started to watch the third one and I got
so stressed that I had to go but there's
also this I'm not going to talk about
what it is but there's another component
to the show that's so creepy and used so
sparingly that I am looking out for it
all the time and I don't even know what
it is or what impact it has on the plot
or anything it's phenomenal and yet like
Jake said Jason Bateman directs a bunch
of the episodes because he he won was it
the what did he win for he beat Game of
Thrones at the Emmys for directing an
episode of Oz are we you know like oh
yeah yeah the incredible Battle of
Winterfell well the incredible power of
Winterfell the episode before that was
better the dark Battle of Winterfell
couldn't see it but no he'd beat out
Game of Thrones and everyone thought
they were shoo-in for supporters of
everyone out there Jason Bateman Jason
Bateman blast to do that and he's kind
of I'm annoyed because it's weekly I
know right what is this I'll wait for my
shows yeah like what is this 90s all
right it's great I recommend you talking
about sex education just reminding me
I'm watching X follows that show is okay
whatever gets you there I guess that
shows that shows on Amazon Prime video
and it looks incredible like it I think
they must build it like on like super
the big question for everyone here
everyone here watch x-files and did you
prefer either watching I'm like I've
never watched it in order so I'm just
like making my way for the firm making
my way don't yeah so I liked
do you prefer the like smoking man main
threads ones or do you prefer the like
monster-of-the-week episode
b201 sir the week does the voice of God
Victor tooms count as monster of the
week or he comes yeah I guess he's like
a refugees in character monster of the
week that graduated yeah he's not the
smoking man like what's going on and
honor I like I like the monster that we
are but they're more likely to have a
weaker episode as well that's true like
the one that I just did was the deal
like the couple who is like a
bank-robbing couple okay and like one of
them gets shot and like transfers into
the body of a cop that also was sure I
was saying okay I was like because like
one of the guys who works for us he's a
head of SEO Chris Pereira like a massive
massive x-files fan so like I submit
like Twitter length reviews to him every
time nicer and like just to keep them
updated yeah something like making my
way free I'm excited to get to the bit
where suddenly the t1000 replaces Mulder
which is gonna be interesting
remember that bit Robert Patrick takes
over Mario he does
I know put it together like when you
said too much yeah me too I I do I had a
buddy or a buddy back home my hometown
Waterford and his next door neighbor
looked identical to Robert Patrick
Patrick's brother used to play in nine
inch nails really and then left just
before they released the downward spiral
no I think there's creative differences
yeah I'm like working my way through
that series which is still very good I'm
mainly boy up say like normal enjoying
good lord
Gillian Anderson looks alien David
Duchovny and Duchovny is rolling Sheila
Anderson's hair and David they just so
on point did they both end up in shows
were sex in Section fee yeah
Instagram by the way incredible just
fashionable she's using like a real
fashionista no she hears their own
fashion line but such that is whenever
she's doing stuff around sex education
she posts pictures of things that
slightly look phallic okay penis of the
day yoni of the day I think to avoid
Instagram I mean I guess I to continue
off these shows I've like binge through
all of succession really good season to
just gets better like I I can't say
enough good things about that show the
acting is incredible like the was Brian
who plays Logan Roy I don't
Brian Cox Brian Cox is absolutely
incredible he plays that character so
well funny I think there was a genuine
x-men to reference in one of the
episodes of succession because what is
it he says to Jason his son has been -
no no he says something and then there's
a bit in succession I come over the line
is but he says it the exact same way
like whispering in someone's ear and I
was thought that going have you seen the
video someone didn't reply thank you of
someone playing every part and it's
Logan won't share his M&Ms cuz he does
all the dressing up he dresses up like
shave and Tom and oh my god do you know
what that shows about I something about
it's like a super rich family business
who's gonna take you so it's like okay
that's a reference not many people it's
it's like a giant media corporation
owned by a family okay I'm sorry yeah
yes and then
the dad this is pretty early on the dad
has like a stroke or something like that
yes so then they try to figure out who's
going to basically take over four hands
well the Culkin's is very good but yeah
that show is very good in theme song -
yeah yeah the song is good I will see
the first two episodes I had trouble
getting into an HBO there is a new
Amanda Iannucci thing that started at
the weekend Oh what is it uh I don't
know it's like you know the answer space
thing yeah it's it's you know the
episode of Futurama where they go on the
cruise yeah because there's something
about the ship not being able to turn
and it can only go straight yeah yeah
yeah and it's Josh GAD and the lady
who's actually in the thick of it so he
plays well the main woman from season 2
I'm very excited to watch that sukhendu
HBO is great Americans know him from
veep I guess did he do that as well yes
didn't make it what was the movie you
did again cuz in the loop you know think
of a song which was the thick of it with
all the same characters but yeah
couldn't have the same name yeah strange
yeah and he's just done the that new one
with Tilda Swinton and the voice of
Paddington Ben Whishaw
and it's what it's called but it's like
someone and Dev Patel is in it and I saw
the trailer and have no idea what it's
called and I regret bringing it up
anyway I mean other than that I'm still
playing modern warfare is the most of a
Call of Duty game I've ever played which
I'm surprised by I actually maybe do
like modern warfare 2 I played more of
but still enjoying that I don't know if
I have much else to say on top of what
I've already been saying about that game
and there's another game I'm playing
that I can't talk about but I'm very
excited to talk about next week
it's very good like you say what country
it's made in or stay not saying anything
other than that it's very good and I
think people will be excited because
it's like a nice
game I can say with the game I just
can't say what you think about what I've
already said I've really liked it so no
I can't different game but I will say I
think people will be excited to play
this game because it comes out in a dry
season especially in with all those game
delays I think it's a it's a good game
that we'll try for the hint dry season
dry spell I thought it was just cuz I'm
sorry I've gone back to games like that
bad then I play it on like know who this
was hard yeah I'm not the original
fallout I'm like oh yeah
anyway moving on to the news we're gonna
talk about cyberpunk 2077 getting
delayed and dying light to getting delay
dying like to that kind of like slipped
under the radar they announced to hit
Monday right when a lot of people at
least in the United States were off on
holiday and it was right now Final
Fantasy port Eckland Tom got me this
Charlie Brown it's well yeah it's
fantastic
oh that's right that's really cool cuz I
had another one and it got stolen it's
nice to people taking Kurt said that we
should don't run this after yeah there's
definitely a quality in the office but
anyway dying light come I feel like a
lot of people didn't notice that it
picked a good time to delay because
everyone say my final fantasy and
cyberpunk yeah we're a spring 2008 the
more than anything else it doesn't have
a date right yeah it's an indefinite the
way they sit in the next couple months
there they will they should have more to
say I have to quote here I'm not gonna
read it because that's pretty much what
it was a flash game was a banger yeah
yeah I support it so long so like I
think they've earned a lot
of goodwill from their audience and I
think they see the potential in what it
could be they got Chris Avalon riding it
right and they have like branching story
it looks like there'd actually trying to
do something substantive I mean even the
last time I Slyke had lots of
interesting like what would you call it
like environmental stuff that bled into
gameplay like with the day/night cycle
and just like that the way you could
tackle all the objectives whatever we
wanted and yeah like it was and the coop
nature that game as well like it was a
lot going on like systems they're very
systems heavy games yeah it's cool that
they're like the narrative like systemic
narrative stuff they're doing is like
I'm sure that is any time anyone's
making anything that's kind of anyway
new or new and genre and your band to
run up against a lot of like unforeseen
problems it's cool that I call it the
Ken Levine problem yeah the narrative
narrative LEGOs was the waiting stick of
bricks ken please link to yeah
it links to a GameSpot Walker where he
uses the phrase narrowed Lego for the
first time in his bio five years ago and
he was just talking about the GDC toca
thing we have on YouTube you and I
talked about it yeah fingers crossed
you know I've alone on it as well it's
uh yeah yeah Dead Island 2 I know it's
not tech band anymore they did that onto
someone did no no it got given - yeah
and then it was soo - no no I remember I
think my first year here I like had to
edit like people went to
Gamescom and they sent back some footage
and I had to edit a video of Dead Island
2 and it seemed like they were playing
it and like they did yeah yeah
what if it's in an IP problem if it bans
me I don't think they were happy with
whatever you did you okay good then I
went to assume oh I am i imagining that
dam Busters hurt I thought damn Buster
had it for a while as war they are they
based in UK hmm home front o new home
front team is that ex Crytek ex Crytek
yeah so yeah that was ex free radical
because they got yeah so I think I'm
busted currently has a November 2019 was
the last time it showed up it's still
occasionally tweet about down Buster
Studios has it currently who's just am
ia that's why they're holding off on the
release day for talking like to cuz it's
just in case they come and don't release
anywhere near that now it's weird though
cuz I really I remember liking dying
light one despite like or sorry Dead
Island one despite all the bugs and I
was excited for yeah I was excited for
Dead Island 2 and then I played dying
light and I was like oh well this is
pretty much their sort of spiritual
successor Techland spiritual successor
but it was still kind of buggy but it
was just more fun and like more fluid
and more frenetic and now I have like I
don't really need that another Dead
Island to like I'll still probably play
it like I'm excited for dying light too
though like that looks fun did I just
say I'm getting confused yeah I did get
it right okay right yeah excited for
dying light too I don't think I need a
Dead Island to at this point one yeah
there we go
how satya about cyberpunk cuz you
tweeted about three days before they
announced I really hope it doesn't get
to it and I was like April 6 can feel it
though I couldn't you April 16 is my
birthday so I was like this is gonna be
the best birthday ever cyberpunk it's
coming on my birthday I was so jazzed
and they announced that release date and
then it just got closer and closer like
we haven't really heard anything I don't
think this is gonna get delayed and sure
enough there is it's gone the statement
they have or we are currently at a state
where the game is complete and playable
but there's still work to be done
CD Projekt RED wrote
release embedded below I forgot to
delete that this is from the article on
gamespot.com they should check that out
night city is massive full of stories
content and places to visit due to the
sheer scale and complexity of it all we
need more time to finish playtesting
fixing and polishing we want cyberpunk
2077 to be our crowning achievement for
this generation and postponing launch
will give the precious months we need to
make the game perfect flying about that
someone who was wrote open article and
it was like cyberpunk delayed because it
doesn't run well on current gen consoles
yes and Cory was just like yeah nothing
runs good two weeks before if anyone has
earned the kind of like trust it's them
they delayed the game and which is too
let's be out like which it too I feel
like that console version was when they
actually that game was good yeah yeah
like the the re-release enhanced video
of it yes that was like I think fixed
yeah I think they've kind of clearly
learned like instead of making an
enhanced edition a few months later
let's just take the extra time and make
a banger from the outside and like the
game now they can afford to write the
games are always like the original
versions of these games are always fine
like just like rough around the edges
but like senior project CD Projekt is
now at a level where Russ had them from
there oh yeah it's now at a stage where
like rough around the edges doesn't play
for them lay there like s-rank developer
now well there were three times more
people they had on which oh right yeah
they kind of need to yeah I like the
expectation for that game yeah like even
they have to do everything in their
power to make sure they can nip and tuck
as many things as possible and like
they've like and the good will like I
said like this but one of the best games
ever made so yeah I feel like they're
definitely they've hit that not quite
there but they they have a similar
mindset or they can't have us in their
mindset to like Rockstar at this yeah I
think it close to rocks I think they're
rocks
like not playing in the same movie not
in terms of sales but like in types of
games that they build for sure yeah did
you hear the IGN UK podcast last week
friend of the show Matt Pirlo was
telling this sort of story about how he
I think was the original witch he bought
it on disk oh yeah and then they
released the enhanced edition or all the
fixes months later but because they were
doing that through Steam he couldn't get
the patch so he had to email CD Projekt
and they said hey I remember because I
was working retail at the time I'm like
the Enhanced Edition came out and they
were like how do i how do I get ya user
email it's weird because I think I was
like at retail for The Witcher 2 as well
right so like I was like both of my The
Witcher releases I've been through
retail yeah and three was the first one
I was like that was that is a wild world
where you need and it was like a zip
file yeah and like you just couldn't
share it yeah sure like email receipt
yeah I mean but this is also a company
that was like founded off of figuring
out how to get pirates to steal things
right they are to start buying games
rather so everything on dog right is
still oh yeah gog is still drm free
right yeah yeah it's interesting I feel
like the the problem I I've always heard
when we recently actually did an
interview it came up again with Gen Z
from supergiant about when they did
transistor and one of the problems a lot
of devs have when creating sci-fi games
if there are contemporary games at all
is that there's way more expectation
about like specific details in those
worlds like will usually go also over
stuff and fineness you games don't think
too much about the way things are
because were not in that world where's
Evie enter a sitting room and I could
contemporary world or a near-future
aesthetic anything like that's a
weird-looking toilet you know what I
mean so requires like a much keener eye
or like once you get down to the end of
it and you're refining the edges just
suddenly a lot more edges to refine so
I was wondering about this one work cuz
obviously the scale of the city you
can't have anything near as big as that
what they made with Witcher cuz it was
all open now and you're at in the world
you know forest and whatnot it's not the
same as this super dense cities then
also those dense cities need to be like
you know you see you saw the demo at e3
right like everything looked like so
yeah interesting every building look
like there's a door you could go in and
see what's inside and so many
advertisements and just layers upon
layers of stuff like reality that they
had and you're thinking like alright how
do you extend that out over like with
your length game well I have a feeling I
have I don't know if I've talked about
my theory I think you're gonna go to the
moon in this game the moon is gonna go
yeah cuz the moon plays a big role in
like the pen and paper RPG oh it does I
know we haven't played yet quick one
they announced it dishonored our beauty
today though we are playing Oh dibs on
Emily but also where the game series
dead dudes on the outsider wait what is
it we should probably move on give me
designers they've been going on a while
but the next big piece of news buyeth
coming to super smash bros ultimate you
guys tried to guess last week no one no
one got it right cally did she wasn't
sure yeah she thought it would be she
was like went very confidently at like
lunch shows like it's gonna be pilot
who's pilots a pile of the main
character and Final Fantasy three houses
but final fun disease oh my god fiery
houses
he watches animate pays final fantasy
dragon quest fan he's got pictures of
Yuji Horii eyes desk exposed anyway yeah
violet has come into super smash bros my
rambling character from Fire Emblem the
main character I didn't know why then
I've played that game yeah people are
mad about it
people are really mad about it get Hill
Doran yes why so I like I I think let
Sakurai duty once that he's already put
in so many great characters in this game
we've got banjo like banjo is in this
game and people are mad because he put
in a fireman character and Sakurai's
favorite series of all time is firing
them just like let them have it they're
gonna add six more characters the way
people are responding is just as well
infuriating like just relax Steve what's
on our news ranked team particle which I
thought was a nice balanced way to kind
of tackle it and look at it look at the
response to it from a more like
reasonable kind of point of view people
are just like real upset about it but
his point was like when when they talked
about the DLC fighters I think it was
Reggie that said it was at the game
Awards the line he used was like these
would be surprising like I said they'll
come from outside and they were
surprised and shocked you or whatever
and the reason why people are and every
character thus far has done that yep and
like banjo not actively yeah a bunch of
other characters Terry Bogard for
example yeah this is the one that breaks
the trend way it's unsurprising in every
way it's a foreign character Nintendo
proppy is favorite it's surprising how
unsurprising it is exactly yeah and I
think that's what people are responding
to in an unreasonable way yeah but like
I thought that was a good smart kind of
assessment of the thing even if it
doesn't forgive the the vitriol that is
being thrown around around it like relax
let let the man like Jake said like he's
he's good
they've given us so many amazing
characters okay there's like seventy
eight or something ridiculous and by the
time they're done there's gonna be
almost 80 over 80 characters
in this game yeah so it's like I'm
definitely one of those people who was
disappointed I woke up at 6:00 a.m. to
see whatever that was
[Laughter]
yeah I looked at it and I saw it was
viola and I was like well I'm going back
to bed and I went back to bed and woke
up and turns out everyone was pissed
yeah well yeah what can you do goodbye
life there's six more coming they
announced instead of five six more by
six more characters come in and the last
piece of new news is Ninja Theory
announces project tomorrow ya know if
you guys saw this the color video video
I watched the video yeah what's up with
the stabilization on that walk I didn't
notice that
Lucy get motion sick that was making me
nothing to desire it should be good
video can be like I mean to be fair like
reading the description project Mara
will be a real world and grounded
representation of mental tear based on
the lived experience accounts and
in-depth research our aim is to recreate
the horrors of the mind as accurately
and realistically as possible project
Mar will be an experimental title and a
showcase of what could be a new
storytelling medium so what they showed
was basically a logo on what look like
it didn't look like general it looked
like video to me did it look like the
video to you oh the shots up the hall
that they had and the typing heat the
hall did the typing on this room but
didn't they cut to like shots that
looked like they were from Hell
BladeCenter was sacrifice but I don't
think they were you worried but it
looked like it was still like rendered
in that engine so I yeah I don't know
yeah they're showing a brain brain waves
and stuff yeah it seems very like we are
thinking like it this seemed to me like
just them trying to almost like a stem
expectation for how they to maybe to be
like look this isn't like a big trimmer
like it like it'll be a smaller thing
again but we're also working on all this
other stuff as well
did it get acquired by Microsoft
Michael's a little bit here they did a
such a great job at representing mental
health aid yeah but why they doubling
down on that for project Mara like it
will be a real real world and grin
erupts into
mental terror which is fine if you're
making a horror game but then it's like
based on real edge experience it counts
an in-depth research our aim is to
recreate the horrors of the mind as a
curator and I suppose like but why so
like they like are you doing that to
like make a horror game are you doing
that to highlight the struggles that
people live with is highlighting those
struggles better and more beneficial
than making something that could help
someone tears like that's the bit but I
appreciate if they didn't the research
and all that stuff but it's a bit weird
I guess like it's hard to say like I'm
trying to think back to playing
hell-blade was there like a there it
does end in a way that kind of cinema's
journey is like she grows like he
struggles throughout the game but
towards the end of the towards the end
of it is like some a moment of
realization piece and she kind of comes
down I think that it's in certainly an
interesting approach for them because
like they I remember talking to me like
the studio had a ninja theory or like
they call themselves head creative ninja
or something like that and I'm like and
he was like very very passionate about
the kind of the process of learning
about psychosis form he'll blades and
were sacrifice and like it was filtered
through that information was filled
through a very specific lens to create
hell-blade I don't know if they if
they're like the wording makes it sound
like the funneling everything they'd
learned down a very like specific genre
path like we're gonna make a dark horror
game but could be that the
representation you know is is kind of
like more it's representing the things
that happen inside the mind in various
ways and hopefully that includes like
how to you know kind of deal with that
stuff yeah and how build I think the
interesting the thing that they were
really proud of is it helped other
people gain an understanding of what it
is like to have psychosis yeah yes even
if it is like on a very basic level like
through binaural audio and other things
that you see in development tricks I
think that's what they're trying to do
now like make that part of the
unique MO and like their their unique
selling point yeah how do we take these
things that people suffer with and kind
of represent them in a way that others
understand and not necessarily like how
do we take this thing that someone
suffers with and turn it into a video
game mechanic well part of me kind of
thinks this may not even be like a video
game
you know like based on that description
I mean I don't know what else would be
but I feel like they've got that
Microsoft money and maybe their team's
probably a lot bigger and they're like
oh you know that's a great show try
other things because I could see that
happening and this sounds bad but when I
read the little press release or
whatever the first thing I thought of
was project milah right just cuz it was
like kind of like a weird experimental
thing that never really made it anywhere
not that this won't but like just at
first glance it was like okay this is
something very different I guess yeah
and like Microsoft is kind of interested
in kind of like that accessibility and
almost like the the health part of it
they've got the adaptive controller
which is something completely different
but like that's a way for people to kind
of like engage people and bring other
people in and enable them to play games
in different ways and like it's almost
like helping the other way around like
helping people who play games to
understand others who are you know going
through certain things and dealing with
with you know day-to-day issues that you
wouldn't be able to see on the face of
them so they they definitely have a
history on exploring that stuff and it
makes sense that if they wanted to do it
it would be ninja theory that does it I
feel like this is a Ninja Theory led
initiative more anything about you know
Microsoft encouraged them to have
inclusive design workshops and then they
apply it to games and so I think the
things just stuck in my craw about that
press release that it's about it's the
phrasing of we just want to show what a
proper representation of mental illness
and whatever and it's like totally but
you just do what we landed on that part
you're not focusing on what it's then
gonna do to people are you doing it to
educate you're doing it to help people
that bit needs to kind of come up in
them the message no yeah it's fake it's
it's it's a very vague announcement and
it's a within a genre or a storytelling
or even a focus like mental health
even there which I feel like this you
know ten years ago there was no mental
health games or get you know when a card
there's at least you know it's on the
tip of everyone's target a lot of game
design is sort of like land into which
is really cool
but I'm yeah it is it's considering how
much of the narrative or like they're
like promotion of said newest sacrifice
or the he'll play both games have been
around that it does seem strange that
they're also doing another one like I'm
with you know like what's the other
what's the unique aspect of this one
then I guess um yeah it's funny got
Microsoft to do in like between this and
double fine it's like I know it's adding
like different colors to the rainbow
which is really important when they're
trying to like create like an idea of
what the Xbox is and especially it comes
to having unique IP which they've had a
massive struggle with this generation
but I'm it is I'm interested it'll be
really weird to see how like these
companies that have kind of like scraped
along doing a lot of this stuff for like
you know would feel like with hell or
with them ninja theory in particular
doing a lot of commercial work so they
could do their of their sort of projects
that made lots of them and it'll be
interesting to see how yeah what happens
if Microsoft are more hands-off with
them and double fine like what the end
up coming off with yeah I mean specially
did you see some of those like
development Diaries for hell-blade where
they like self-motion like on the on the
ceiling it's like this really janky set
of it was just like like dang they like
pinched every penny to get this game
made which is we have a mini talk about
that on game smart I think that's
actually all right oh yeah was it like a
triple-a game on a double-a budget
anyway we've been going on a while and
we've got some questions we got some
questions for you Danny and then we have
some listener questions we'll go through
these questions for you
fairly quickly sure they're just from
Twitter the first one is from the
wonderful rep Ford Danny yes yes from
all your visits to various developers
what would you say the closest universal
truth is is there something that stands
out first of all a great video on cable
car yeah Mike my Hardy talking the rep
for words we had
inherited Dan records giant pencil
didn't e yeah is that what it was
yeah um did that's what was it it was
like every what would every celebrities
em universal truth I think maybe the
thing this the thing that I've come to
personally sort of understand or change
my mind around it
when it comes to games is that like even
the games that you think are like
cynically made for money and like
everyone on it moving on everyone maybe
that's too broad but like everyone's
most of them are like breaking their
arses off it and they know like any
problems that exist with games most of
the time the developers know and it
wasn't an issue of them not trying hard
enough
sometimes it was time sometimes it was
budget sometimes it was the team
composition sometimes it was team
politics but like everyone's trying
their best and really trying to make the
best thing they can I would like to
advise to the team behind but I think if
there's one universal thing actually
it's probably um I remember when I was
in the like working this side of the
price cuz it does feel different they're
doing doing the noclip stuff and because
we're not sort of on the beat as much
like you're not like in time with
everything as much and especially what
reviews new stuff that like you kind of
felt like you were in a like a you felt
victimized a bit because you're always
getting criticized for stuff like people
always criticizing you for review scores
or for thinking something or when I had
my uh paid show like oh but what about
this or whatever and then when you talk
to developers and gamers as well gamers
feel that way too they feel like they're
getting nickel and dimed by Studios or
publishers or like the game they like
they made a sequel that I don't like
that sequel I'd prefer that was like
that one why did you make make it more
like New Vegas not like fallout 3 you
know like that type of thing all right
and and but then we talk to developers
they feel the exact same way cuz they're
like oh everyone criticizes us through
like reviews are always bad or like this
gamers are giving out to us or saying we
don't care or anything so I think
learning that like developers feel as
isolated as everyone else cuz they're
just stuck in like revs in London
Ontario we're working on that game right
in a small
small town they don't feel like they're
you know the part of this massive
multimillion-dollar engine or this game
that star 20 well if they feel scrappy
they were you know scrappy to the end
with that and I think that's I think
when you meet developers like there are
those egos which I think - I think we
ran into more here where's like here I
was exposed to more and it's definitely
changed you look at stuff like audio
logs you talk and everyone but like III
stage show you're generally talking to
you get the media trained totally this
is the face this is PR marketing
approved facial dissonance everything
answer for everything that type of thing
blazer over there lovely people but they
give an impression of confidence and I
think that is actually where a lot of
gamers react to which is that they think
there's so much competencies to is you
go talk to these people I just talking
to somebody's been working on like the
sound design for this one game in secret
for six [ __ ] years and yeah and of
course they they care more than anyone
else about hookah what people say where
their game so I think that's I think
more than anything else it's that and
that's why I've like struggles to like
do any op ed stuff since I left because
I'm just like they know like what am I
gonna say yeah I mean so it's a it's
tough it's uh yeah that's that's
probably the thing everyone is you know
scrappy trying their best they're not
similar to us a lot of places like I
said the the easy thing to do a few
years back was when a game came out and
you didn't like some aspect about it you
cry about it yeah but I hate this part
again because XYZ should be done like
this now like we've just become one
we're more aware of the fact that
everyone knows yeah people there's no
benefit to telling someone who knows
that something's bad is bad like or is
is compromised and to like the general
negativity around yeah it's just like
all-encompassing yeah like and I know
from like an editorial team like we
don't mince our words
mmm like these days I think a lot of
people they edge towards like how can I
find something positive in like you look
at the stuff that Mike Marty does for
example yeah like a lot of the things
that he does are finding the positive
parts of in games and are trying to find
something small and like talk about this
element of the game and like why it's
good for him and like I heard like a lot
of people are doing that and
everyone's leaning towards that now a
bit more so like yet that what you said
there's like pretty much on the money
for a lot of people but it's a funny
balance right because then if you start
doing that too much too much all you're
doing is like don't shake up the arson
and you're just yeah I like like I said
like where as a team it's something that
we we very much are aware of and focus
on balancing yeah I will never be like
this game is bad let's not review it all
right yeah it's bad like let's sugarcoat
it like we always tell it how is but I
back in the day it was like we need an
op ed let's find something to pick on
yeah like I'm not saying that's what we
even if you weren't in saying that it
was thinking it or it was it was it was
a matter it was a gravity that was there
like you can see in the tone of like
YouTube essays yeah yeah totally Oh back
in the day it was like every youtuber si
would be like this is why this thing is
bad yeah like X reasons why this is bad
now it's my how this game got murdered
yeah yeah no it's now it's like oh this
this thing that's kind of like perhaps
not super popular there's actually
something really cool in here and that's
the kind of tone of YouTube essays and I
feel like that's partly you ever
consciously or subconsciously a response
to the general negativity around games
and also like the the awareness that the
people who make things also aware of
their their flaws yeah and like they
don't need to be like kicked when
they're down yeah let's try and find
something positive and I think that at
least for the people in this room like
that's there's something that we kind of
gravitate towards right yeah yeah
next you'll reach your videos really
good yeah next question would you would
love to know what perspective his work
with noclip has given with regards to
how games are made opposed to it kind of
already answered that question
yeah the same thing they take a long
time everyone works pretty hard they're
totally broken until the last minute
because like we especially with the hey
with the Haiti stuff were working on now
yeah we were supergiant were based in
San Francisco just down the road Greg
Savin X editor GameSpot and super
building the bastion see a show on
giantbomb where they showed that game
being built so we've been embedded with
them throughout the development of Hades
and I have access to daily builds and
weekly builds that they send out to the
QA people so whenever there were
capturing gameplay for stuff as it's get
changed or stuff that's like you know I
need gameplay for an air because the
video is going out in two weeks or
whatever and it'll be it'll good playing
catch-up and like yeah like their game
is actually like they're probably the
most disciplined most like you know
their version controlling and everything
is like slick but even at that stage
everything is just like a broken mess
um and it's yeah it's it's it's funny
when people say that like a good example
of this actually was em what was like
what was the game that came out near the
end of the year that just needed to be
baked a little bit longer fallen order
yes Yellin order was a really good
example of kind of like when you've just
not screwed the IKEA furniture that a
little bit more I've got one in a donkey
and the whole thing leans and it's only
because of one or two screws and it's
like yeah it's that thing it's so
prevalent but it's so difficult to to do
and yeah I don't know I think in a world
where there were gold dates it was a
little bit easier maybe and then the the
day one patch is kind of in a way maybe
made stuff harder for people but yeah
the the Haiti series you guys are doing
is really cool just because that is
something you don't really see like a
lot of it's you get the preview stuff
and then maybe after you get post-mortem
like here's kind of how it went here's
the struggles we had but you never see
like in the thick of it back in the day
there was a game series I think be
Peoria yeah do you remember that that's
never came out yeah there was a series
back in there we both used to watch it
was caught it was called something else
but the game was yeah but there was a
game called like black powder red it
wasn't in development it was something
like that yeah it was like Ryan McDonald
and those guys they were like embedded
with a team who was making this like
sci-fi shooter game yeah and like it was
like weakly behind the scenes my god it
was incredible and that games vanished
there are no unique ideas everything
I did it totally yeah yeah it's like all
right I did like when we do like one-off
interview things and like the one I
always remembered in my head was this
show on gamespot back in the day that
was called and what was it called it was
like it was they'd interview there was a
couple of later interviewed Molyneux and
a couple of people and he's one off then
Afeni it was Jeff Keeley it actually
produced no wasn't finalized but they
were they were right up Sunday yeah but
there was a video series behind the
games yeah they might have been lost in
the grace yeah so will who works on
engineering he actually was just showing
me the other day that basically all like
our first videos that we've posted if
you go to our video page and scroll all
the way to like page 3000 you can find
it and it's like gameplay movie cutscene
one game play move big things right
embedded in articles but you can
actually find that in life the other day
and I was looking for we had yacht club
in yes to shoot audio logs and he was
David DeAngelo I was asking for you know
we're gonna compare this with this do
you have gameplay this so I was going
back through the old games for archives
we used to call things instead of just
saying gameplay we used to call it
Splosion man gameplay movie yeah yeah
and we would doing that until about 2011
doesn't really normal out in Teague it's
like page two thousand a thousand pages
it was Slayer right a lot of them are
just like we were at a bar and we'll
just starts playing like random
cutscenes from games from gods and years
ago because lark over there pulling the
downloading off is oh yeah I was like a
super small subsection the users that
did it but they were like important
users you want to piss off yeah they
were me I was
one guy in the UK the motor VCDs and I
genuinely had like 250 oh my god I think
I still have this stack it was like I
probably got a comprehensive history of
gamespot videos some few if any of my
old blog videos cuz they're mostly gone
okay I definitely got the bow shock what
you do unloaded the bash of my niece in
with ya when you're sitting in the tub
as well yeah yeah we put some weird
stuff they shouldn't have let use no
videos next one since he spent so much
time covering the stories of games from
behind the scenes does he ever think
about how he would run his own studio
also does he remember when we all sang
karaoke in Tokyo with Japanese
businessmen and called blessing was from
Ian why not yeah yeah we yeah that was
that was for we did that we did a
meet-up in Japan and way more people
turned up to me and Jeremy were
expecting like like 40 people or
something and like hang the Tokyo bars
the yeah what was the question it was
them how would you run your own studio
given what gosh like I'm sure I've
pulled in ideas about running our
current studio of me and Jeremy and from
from places I've worked before I did
like try I wanted to work in games
because as a web developer programmer
and I studied c-sharp and did XNA I mean
my final college program was it was a 2d
platformer game that I coded but like I
didn't have the discipline first I don't
have like the attention for the thing I
loved if I'm working in video when I
worked in web development you'd work in
a project for like couple of months and
then it was like like a chain around
your neck for the rest of your life
because used to constantly like as the
internet updated you to constantly work
on this website so you just build up
this like massive amount of like collars
that you had to constantly keep fixing
um and what I liked about what made me
fearful about games was working on a
project for five years I don't think I
had their like ability to like work on
something creative the idea that long
where's video stuff you know you can
work on something for
weaker like two days or you can wear
know something for like the longest
projects we've had have maybe been two
months of post-production and it's
that's fine because you know what you
can see the end of the tunnel
yeah I think about that sometimes too
because I've been here for five years
almost now and I'm like that's a long
time that it was like if I was working
on a game that would be that would be
like one shipped game could you imagine
yeah and then like we talked a lot of
like developers and they've you know
they'll they'll have symptoms like like
something akin to like a postpartum
of-of what do you do once this big the
way you've lived your life and focused
in this thing you've like tried to
create is suddenly out in the world and
you don't have control over it anymore
or like what do you do with that and the
massive yeah like problems trying to get
back from that so yeah
yeah it's great it is interesting going
to different studios and learning the
different ways to culture works and the
big thing I look for when we're trying
to see if a place is like cuz everyone's
trying to put on a good face for us and
ultimately when you like telling these
stories you're you're picking a version
of the lie like you'll never get close
to the truth you'll never have all the
truth so you sort of like try and find
as close to the the the the the lie you
want to tell and for me figuring out
whether in other places were like
righteous or not is looking at tenure
and looking at like how long people have
been there like what the average tenure
is like how many what type of people
they employ like I diverse the
workforces how if people have like been
promoted like all that sort of stuff and
you can get a real sense of it and it's
funny like I'm sure one day we'll do
like a like a breakdown of like the ones
that are really not good and the ones
that are but um it's I think that's the
biggest sense for me of like whether how
well a place is run is whether or not
people stick around like how about that
turnover is yeah I think the average
turnover the average job in bgs
maryland's the average tenure I think
was 12 years that's why I'm like geez
whoa and they get more [ __ ] than anyone
yeah yeah they take care of their people
yeah
his tenure I think is like 20-something
last last question in the dancer's
section if noclip got a killer netflix
deal what would you do with an unlimited
budget at least for two seasons before
you're cancelled that's pretty
soon man it's too soon to talk about
mine time yeah that's a travesty boy and
I'd love to do something there I think
if we did it would have to be something
that was way more mainstream focused
focusing on like I think my favorite
thing about um a bet like like Netflix
is like full it's like there's more
documents than anything else people are
throwing monies documentaries and then
whenever anyone tries to make a
documentary about games it's like the
history of games yeah it's like it's
like e rice do you remember that and the
Bev events like can you imagine going on
like that documentary about finding a
CPT one yeah and that was a poster for
do I think with Microsoft Microsoft yeah
but I know the folks over to other ocean
he was boring yeah yeah well they picked
they dug him up and they were there it's
the same story it's like the Loch Ness
monster be boring if you found it it's
more and well maybe it wouldn't but the
thing that they keep doing is that and
it's really weird is like it's like you
don't go to like the documentary section
and like here's the like the history of
food it's just like it's so such an
egregious ly broad way of tackling it
but that's the way everyone does it
who's he going food documentaries it's
like every little tiny little slice so
like I don't know I think ultimately the
stories that are interesting when it
comes to documentaries are not talking
heads Wikipedia articles Dhirubhai
people and there's a couple of like
specific stories that we've kind of like
dawn or maybe like one would like lean
into more if we had the opportunity to
do them like with a more substantial
crow or more time more than anything
else because time is the most expensive
thing especially on like I feel like if
you're gonna shoot a Netflix documentary
right that's probably like a year and a
half like that's gonna take a while it
won't understand and then to do that
we'd still need to obviously keep up
everything on the noclip side as well
yeah you couldn't what are you doing
then cuz like the big what we like about
our stuff is that it'll exist no it's
out in the world and people can have it
in there's no ads and they can you know
it's Netflix to that well that's totally
100 percent so like what are you doing
at that stage you just you're doing
commercial work and maybe that story
could should be told for everyone for
free but I international like as well we
have a lot of people who watch outside
of english-speaking territories and
stuff so um yeah I think there is
something to be done I think
yeah when the story presents itself I'd
be right probably push harder on it for
this great series on Netflix called hip
hop evolution
oh yeah which is like charts the history
of hip hop start to current day but it's
like through the people that were there
as much as they can or the people that
they were influenced by go watch the
color like so yeah that's real good it's
like maybe two seasons not super long
but like each and it's like it's got
like well-known rappers right I like
talking about oh yeah I was coming up
and this was the sound and then I took
this in there and like there's something
that could be made in in that similar
vein for games where it's like you could
probably get pretty far back with like
original developers but then it's like
almost like trying the real a race of
the of like the development of video
games like I saw this and I always
influenced this and then my thing
influence the next generation it's
harder I feel like with games to have
that sort of like personal through line
because you'll have these people who are
like saying the producers develop or
whatever and they're like they are the
emotional core but when you and you can
do it somewhat with games but then you
get into 90s and suddenly teams start
ballooning and you don't have
individuals yeah tell the story that way
so it's it's really for me ESPN 30 for
30s we're like that was the big
inspiration for noclip was like I don't
know each of these stories is its own
little thing and you tell it its own way
like thirty four thirty you know
anything that ties them together is
basically the logo at the start yeah
head sided out it could be Ice Cube
talking to you about the Oakland Raiders
it could be this like there's one that's
just about this one day in time it was
the date at OJ's was in the car chase
and it was a bunch of other like sports
things like the form can adapt to the
story and that's the most important
thing so you can tell the story the best
way can be told instead of having the
box and I'm trying to fit things into
the box so yeah it's it's I'd love to
yeah that's why our stuff doesn't have
much performing either like some of them
are big series some of them are small
things and so the problem with Netflix
is that you kind of need to formalize it
so there's show yeah so it's so it's
hard to say what that thing would be one
of the more thinking about that one of
the league's one of my favorite videos
that I've worked on since I've been here
was or series of videos was Mike and I
and Richard kind of like followed the
immersive sim and we talked to we talked
like Harvey
Smith and Raph call Antonio but then we
also talked to we also talked to like
Richard Garriott and what's-his-name he
loves Mickey Mouse made one of the games
we film day he was like this is my
Mickey Museum you know pretty much we
walked in and there was just like so
much there's Mickey mean the same thing
in England as doesn't Ireland taking the
piss technology literally means like
penis would like to come out of that was
we had we interviewed Richard Garriott
and that guy is really smart like oh
yeah like his like a polymath yeah his
brain is just on another level and he we
asked him like so what is it that makes
like immersive Sims really special
okay well let's when people play games
they want as many options they can let's
say this place is on fire and he starts
listing all these things like we try to
break through the window but the though
it's it's wired glass we can't get
through it okay well what if we what if
we get through the door we can't get
through the door because it's locked to
the the handles are hot so we can't do
that and he's like going through all
these scenarios in his head and he just
like one after the other like this is
how we get out if there was a fire and
and we're like okay that that's pretty
cool there was a match in the floor yeah
no but we were editing it and I was
sitting next to Richard at time in trees
like this guy's really smart and and
then Richard does some research and he's
like wait a second he said the same
exact thing or a notable times for a
different interview
got a bunch of interviews I do the same
thing the worst thing we're not having
say anyway a little bit of a tangent but
now we're on to the listener questions
there's not a whole lot but yeah if you
guys have questions make sure to email
email us at after dark podcast at
GameSpot calm is our favorite part of
the show where we get to answer your
questions so please send them our way
Lucy do you wanna read the first one
okay this is from Sam from Atlanta
hey y'all been an avid listener since
episode one and quickly came to love the
relaxed atmosphere in the podcast week
to week we don't like beer have you done
it earlier for me is that what happened
yeah yes it's alright thank you probably
shouldn't drink and work out nice to
drive back to the yes I did my question
is though assuming you have some of the
GameSpot video producers
on this week how did you get to that
position I'm a recent college graduate
myself doing freelance work and would
love to some day work that job for a
gaming site any advice thanks so much
Sam from Atlanta PS I really hope the
answer isn't just blind luck cuz I'm
just not that lucky I think you should
go first my answer is you and cam and
Seb so yeah we I get maybe it's
different in different countries as well
I guess
am i I think just like have it's really
difficult right because I don't like I
think being having a portfolio of work
is like the most important thing I felt
like or being able to show to be able to
learn I guess
we should just get Chris in here to
answer the question because he was gonna
hired me so when I turn up late for that
[ __ ] interview so God knows why I got
the job and yeah I don't know I think
like both I actually that absolutely
yeah but there's a lot of people who
write try to write entirely on passion
or enthusiasm which i think is like such
a funny like you need to be you need to
have like passions really go but if you
can't back it up with like actual work
and if you can't accept criticism
yes 100% yes like I've been in loads of
interviews I have both sides of the
table right I think anyone who's hired
someone can speak to this
people can tell when you're faking
something no one yeah oh yeah faking
experience people will immediately
figure out what what you're better off
doing is showing passion and a genuine
willingness to gain the experience that
the person wants yeah so like holding
your hands up and being like listen I
don't have that much offense but I
really love this thing
I work so hard I know that I've got this
foundational knowledge and I can build
on it is way more likely to keep you in
that person's mind then being like yeah
I can do you know after thank you after
effects the difficulty I think here
maybe for video stuff is that there
aren't very many like except for when
you do internships like entry-level
positions because cost of living here so
high so like it's it's you know no one
has expected anyone to have professional
experience generally having a YouTube
channel and having some sort of like
having YouTube channel and having an
audience is obviously wonderful but just
having a YouTube channel that shows like
work that you've been creating and some
like level of frequency or or that
there's an evolution there I think that
goes a long way as well but like it's
weird because then there's always the
tantalizing like you know twitch and
YouTube sort of lifestyle over here and
I yeah I don't know I've met a lot of
twitch and YouTube people a lot of
people who work in games coverage and I
think games coverage is a far better
lifestyle but better type of work he got
to work collaborative people you get to
sleep and especially mr. people's having
kids it's real difficult in that world
so yeah I yeah I mean I I got a little
lucky I think but but the big I was just
making videos I was making videos I was
writing articles my friends and I
started like a small gaming website we
had almost no audience but the reason I
got it was because I got lucky and
checked job openings one day or a friend
sent me a job opening he was like hey
there's a video internship this sounds
like your kind of thing and I applied
and I think the reason I got it the
reason I got in the door the reason I
got an interview if like tie and they
thought was because like they were just
had like a long list of videos that I
had already made like I was already
doing it and it was clear that I still
had a long way to go but it was like
okay there was a foundation here that
you can see and can work with and I
actually was part of the hiring process
for hiring our intern Evan and I
interviewed a couple people and what
Tamar was saying is like you can tell
when someone's faking it like I
obviously not gonna say any names but
someone I was like like what do you like
about GameSpot like do you follow us on
like did you check our news he's like
actually I get news from like you like
for a while he was saying like oh yeah
like yeah I like this and then
eventually at one point he was like oh
yeah I get my news from IGN yeah and I
was like I mean that's not bad
fine I about it that was the thing like
he was trying to like talk about all
these things on GameSpot that he really
likes and I was like those don't we
don't really do that kind of stuff like
I was the critical of GameSpot when I
came in for my interview because I've
been a five but I was a consumer of it
but I've been on it for like whatever
seven six six years well at that stage I
was like these things are good and these
things are yeah honesty is way more
important than you know yep and that I
didn't have any video experience when I
got my internship but you worked in
television after that right after yeah
but no when when I got my internship I'd
only ever been writing for my friends
like enthusiast site right and my
university paper and then Alex Sassoon
Kobe was me and I think I don't even
think video came up until I started and
were kind of rolling everyone into video
that size right yeah and my my second my
first day it was hey you wanna come see
how we make start select and it was
seven Jane doing it and then you got me
dude I was in escape from my stupid a
cop right that was I guess technically
my first ever funny thing and then I buy
it because I was that for a month
and they would just give me like I
remember working with you to cut some
call of duty we remember we used to do
feature rappers oh yeah yeah ones get
all the meat off the Buffalo yeah yeah
all those oh that kind of like little
things and little jobs did sort of teach
me how to edit and then by the end of
the internship I was doing I did video
features I did yeah like on camera stuff
and then I went to work for do you
become yeah totally you're killing it so
thank you yeah
it's very it's very it's different ways
of doing it yeah I think it's but to
what you were saying it's the passion
and willingness to learn and I and
getting your hands like you were like a
lot of people have
museum but like ever I feel like
everything that you got thrown out you
were actually able to do or or if you
weren't you there was no there was none
of that like you know trying to keep it
to yourself and then [ __ ] yeah two hours
before the embargo yeah the case with
everyone that Chris got on actually
because Karen was the same way Kyle put
his hands up the minute if you do
anything could put his hands up that was
opposite you right and so as well and
instead was around and so I felt like I
was in a safe enough environment that I
could just say hey guys there's no you
go there yeah it was great like yeah I
really like that there I learned a lot
there yeah I think another important
thing that we talked about too on a
previous episode is just oh don't burn
yourself out especially like if you're
trying to build up like a portfolio
before you apply or whatever like yeah
don't like don't don't kill yourself
freaking like one video every couple
weeks that's solid and like yeah well
fall out and doesn't have to be
elaborate just be like decently shot and
a good sound like you know the basics
it's like they're just do that
frequently and when someone on the video
team looks at you and sees like this
consistency and a baseline fundamental
or they just see potential that's the
important thing like is if you don't
have the experience give the person who
potentially going to hire you the
opportunity to see that if they invest
in you you will deliver something for
them because that's what ultimately what
people want right like companies like
ours they're willing to find someone who
doesn't have a lot of experience because
they know they can sync time and money
into creating you into something cool
and they will benefit them so like
showing that willingness to learn and
passion and not burning out or super
quickly and then having like this
massive gap that happens a lot where
people are like I stopped Ryan yeah the
first one again is like you had it you
had it going but I need something recent
yeah since them yeah you'll read the
next question tomorrow
sure yeah what question is I got a I'd
like his I'm also like on borrowed time
here okay okay sorry there's no
interview a four o'clock
work never stops so why don't we just do
yeah why don't we just do this one and
then we'll call it it sorry mysterious
other emailing
hey all been avid listener since episode
1 I did is that you do yes
oh is it this game of the year 1 yeah oh
we read this already okay
Dec Rhonda yeah just listen to your game
of the air pocket enjoy discussion on
Sakura and it's connection to sangoku
Japan this has always been one of my
favourite pieces of history but inspired
by a different game kesan for the
PlayStation 2
obviously Kohi provides a gateway into
history and their games from Three
Kingdoms from Nobunaga's ambition but
what are some other examples of games
have unlocked interested in the real
world did you start reading about
defense tration or Prague after playing
Kingdom Come deliverance or did Bubba as
you things to look for more logic
puzzles oh goody
I played Sakura now my swordsman PS
there's more who's on the other side I
don't think it's a question it's just ok
PS James klevens book Shogun is set in
the San Goku era will be adapted into an
FX miniseries already won it was already
won in 1980 if you're interested in a
period it's also an interesting read
thank you Andrew I've had that with a
lot of sports where like I played
Formula one games and got into Formula
One or hockey like ice hockey in
American football from like Madden and
NHL and stuff like that where it's
literally teaching you gameplay
mechanics which also are real-world
gameplay mechanics yeah yeah it's a
pretty easy one to translate over yeah
mine is probably control I think a lot
of people in this office to just did a
lot because it plays with a lot of
real-world theories and stuff like that
and then I did a lot of research along
with Peter Brown just trying to figure
out what the heck some of the stuff they
were talking about and then followed up
like I know Mike has been talking about
house of leaves I think talked about a
lot on giant beast cast and I finally
started reading that just because
because of control and how control is
based on I don't know it's not
necessarily learning facts or you know
like new skills but I'd say that would
be SVP yeah I can't think of much less
excel for me like I think don't you
already knew everything I know
everything I think David delving deeper
into like a blood-borne made me more
interested in Lovecraft mmm-hmm which
was where's a massive races off him
because I bought the Necronomicon and I
read it I was like no well and I know
like not read the HP Lovecraft stuff but
I've been more yelling into stuff that
was inspired by a but isn't cosmic
harmony part here basically I've been
playing about bones right for me it's my
psychology of game design oh cool yeah
and yeah because I did it I called you'd
agree yeah I hated sorry University of
Leeds because it's not they barely
taught you anything that was applicable
to like a real life example and so when
you you look at closer a game design and
why designers do things and how it kind
of messes with not messes of the
psychology but taps into the innate
psychological processes that you have in
how it that relates to real life I find
that very interesting I was late for my
law exam because I was on the toilet
playing Phoenix right once thematically
accurate nice objection
what time was it was it just you I was
always scheduled like because I was I
got there too early because I'm as good
you can attest who I'm like whenever
there's an appointment for me to go from
where I overcompensate so like I'll turn
up to the airport five hours early so
shared cabs I was so I showed up to my
exam two hours early I was like what am
I gonna do I was like well I'll just you
know get the most satisfying experience
I can by playing Phoenix right well a
lot of them got really like enveloped in
a case and then like looked at my watch
I was like oh man one of my favorite two
more stories for that stuff is a he used
to work in a store on one end of the
central line and he lived like I don't
know five stops from the end the central
line yeah it was and he fell asleep one
time and you ended up in Essex and then
you fell asleep on the way back in a
package
we're just up and down like in one poor
guy it's like two hours you today anyway
that's about as good as time as anything
yes Lucy James work if people find you
on twitter at least in james games Danny
pull anything you wanna plug out on your
dryer hit no clip on your internet
search machine you might hit us the
Patriots the pay and the Hugo Martin
interview podcasters yeah that went up
last week and we have a native thank you
and we did we did were shot a very small
interview would he go about the demons
that are in the game which will be up so
now it depends on how fast I can edit it
tomorrow watch this space I'm at more
age on 12 all right you can find me at
jacob deck and once again email your
questions to after dark podcast at
gamespot.com do it and yeah make sure to
go to GameSpot comm check us out
[Music]